zombies are officially back in black ops
cold war yakuza leica dragons release
date is moving
up a few days and you'll be able to play
as virgil in dmc 5 on the current
gen i'm persia and this is your save
state for monday
september 28th
activision has confirmed that zombies
are back in black ops cold war
and a full reveal is coming this
wednesday a quick animation was tweeted
that simply shows some key art for the
mode but
it's also official confirmation of what
fans have been wanting
and what activision has been hinting at
in the recent months
a beta for black ops cold war is also on
its way for october
but it's unclear whether zombies will be
in that or not the full reveal at 10 a.m
pacific on wednesday should tell us more
so make sure you come back to gamespot
for
all of the juicy details when it happens
here's something we don't hear too often
nowadays the western release date for
yakuza like a dragon
has been moved up the release date for
all the versions except for the ps5 will
be aligning with the release of the xbox
series x
and s on november 10. if you want to
play it on the ps5 then you'll have to
wait until march of next year
but keep in mind that it will be out on
the ps4 on the same day as the other
consoles and you'll get
a free upgrade to the ps5 version when
it's out however you won't be able to
transfer your save file
you'll also be able to upgrade your xbox
one version to the next gen with the
added perk of being able to cross save
which is a feature
exclusive to the xbox version so which
version of leica dragon are you gonna
get
if you've been feeling like you need
more power in dmc 5
then get motivated because virgil will
be a playable character
in the dlc for the special edition okay
umvc3 references aside devil may cry 5
special edition is coming to the next
gen this november
but the dlc itself will be released at a
later date
in good news for the current gen owners
the dlc will also be available on the
ps4
xbox one and pc versions the trailer
showed off virgil in action
executing some of his iconic moves along
with other familiar members of the cast
also making an appearance for the next
in versions of the special edition you
can expect the usual features like ray
tracing
and a 120 fps mode and there's more dlc
to come
tomorrow there will be a live stream for
the pokemon sword and shields
crown tundra expansion we also have a
ton of new series x coverage because we
actually have the console now
so check out gamespot.com for all the
latest on that
thanks for tuning in and we will catch
you at your next save state
tomorrow see ya
you